pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à toi
non
le 20 août 1940
léon trotsky était assassiné à mexico je
vous laisse à penser ce que cette
nouvelle en d'autres temps est connu
comme commentaire dans notre pays parce
que s'il est un personnage qui a
passionné les français
entre autres bien sûr c'est léon trotski
mais le 20 août 1940 la france battue
humiliée occupés qui se cherche qui ne
comprend plus un million et demi de
prisonniers alors la mort de léon
trotsky quelques lignes dans les
journaux la zone occupée où la zone
libre trotsky assassiné à mexico et
depuis depuis pas grand chose
bien sûr des livres dont certains
excellents et notamment celui de julian
gorkin un film de l'osé mais on n'a pas
beaucoup lu ses livres et on n'a pas
beaucoup vu ce film
il ya même une pièce caisses allemandes
de peter weiss grands auteurs j'ai parlé
avec le directeur qui a monté cette
pièce en allemagne il m'a dit vous
comprenez les non communiste n'aime pas
trop de ski alors ils sont pas venus les
communistes m encore moins 3 de ski et
ne sont pas venu non plus ça a été un
succès alors finalement je crois que
beaucoup de gens se posent encore des
questions sur la mort de trotski et je
crois qu'il est utile de chercher à y
répondre parce que au fond cette
position du directeur de théâtre
allemand elle est très critiquable
je n'aime pas ce genre de position qui
laisserait croire qu'il n'ya qu'une
vérité quand on a un peu étudié
l'histoire on s'aperçoit que la vérité a
presque toujours deux visages
et quand tous les cas la vérité n'est
jamais entièrement d'un seul côté
répondons à cette curiosité
essayons de savoir comment trotski est
mort mais essayons aussi de savoir
pourquoi trotsky m
alors cette histoire
cette histoire c'est avant tout
l'histoire de deux hommes c'est
l'histoire de deux hommes dont l'un
s'appelle trop de skier l'autre
s'appelle staline deux hommes qui ont
connu pendant des années de longues
années un affrontement qui atteint tous
les paroxysmes la haine la volonté
d'abattre l'autre d'anéantir l'autre et
disons que ces deux hommes écrivent à
eux seuls une tragédie parce que les
tragédies par essence c'est un paroxysme
et pourtant au départ ces deux hommes
étaient semblables s'étaient des
révolutionnaires des révolutionnaires
authentiques tous les deux mais
différent et ça c'est important
différent celui qui va nous occuper ne
s'appelait pas trop de ski à l'origine
les s'appelait léon davidovitch
bronstein c'était le fils de paysan aisé
du sud de l'ukraine des paysans juifs
il fait des études à 18 ans il est
étudiant et il est déjà révolutionnaire
nous sommes à la fin du 19e siècle à une
époque où la russie connaît le régime
autocrate d'état autocratique et il y à
toute une poignée de gens qui voudraient
que ça change
une poignée de gens qui préparent
justement ce changement dans la
clandestinité en conspirant en
travaillant l'étudiant
et le jeune léon bronstein est arrêté et
jeté en prison
envoyés en sibérie lé s'évader en
s'évadant il emprunte le nom du gardien
de sa prison trotsky et c'est ainsi
qu'il entrera dans l'histoire comme léon
trotski alors là il rejoint en europe
occidentale
lénine lénine qui lui aussi prépare la
révolution en exil et avec lui il
collabore à la première revue au premier
organe de la révolution russe en exil
lys gr
les deux hommes collaborent étroitement
s'estime mais s'affrontent déjà parce
que trotski est un intraitable
trotsky c'est l'homme qui dans une
discussion ne veut pas fléchir prod ce
qui est sûr de détenir le vrai côté mais
l'autre aussi alors il faut qu'il y en
ait toujours un qui cède est jamais trop
ce qui ne veut céder alors il ya ces
affrontements ces affrontements entre
lénine et trotski est cependant 1905
bien sûr 30 ce qui se trouve à saint
pétersbourg pour la première révolution
russe il préside le soviet de saint
pétersbourg et puis plus tard quand ce
soviets sera arrêté trotsky sera arrêté
lui aussi il sera libéré par une grande
campagne internationale car son nom est
déjà connue à travers le monde exil de
nouveau la tente et enfin c'est 1917 de
new york au mois de mai 1917
trotsky arrive à saint-pétersbourg au
mois de juillet trotsky va adhérer au
parti bolchevik avec ses amis et en
octobre il est au premier rang
avec lénine avec ce merdeux l'ofs avec
staline aussi pour faire la révolution
socialiste et lénine c'est à quel point
tout ce qui compte dans cette révolution
il exerce au lendemain de la révolution
un pouvoir immense
il semblerait qu'ils puissent tout
obtenir ils couchent dans le palais des
tsars mais on fera de lui un commissaire
du peuple aux affaires étrangères
d'abord est un peu plus tard un
commissaire du peuple à la guerre et
c'est là qu'il va donner sa mesure
c'est là que pendant deux ans et demi
sillonnant la russie dans son fameux
train blindé
il est partout à la fois chaque fois que
dans la guerre civile
blanc contre roues chaque fois que lie à
un point qui est menacée bien voilà
trotsky qui arrivaient tout à coup il
galvanise les hommes le commandement les
soldats le peuple ils gagnent elles
gagnent toujours on peut dire que il est
l'un des premiers fondateurs de l'armée
rouge et il est heureux qu'aujourd'hui
après des polémiques compréhensible il
est aujourd'hui il est heureux
qu'aujourd'hui on le reconnaissent et
même parmi les rentes des écrivains
communiste français après la victoire
il retrouve lénine s'affrontent encore à
lénine parce que ça c'est trotsky trop
ce qui a toujours une vérité toute
trotsky toujours la peau proclamé cette
vérité il tenir plus qu'à tout mordicus
évidemment toujours pour s'affronter à
quelqu'un il s'affronte est à l'aîné il
se rapproche de lénine pourtant avant
l'âme la maladie au moment de la maladie
de celui ci avant sa mort et quand
lénine mais quand la russie sans deuil
et bien deux hommes maintenant vont
s'affronter mais beaucoup plus
cruellement parce que les affrontements
avec lénine c'était disons
de la doctrine et les deux hommes garder
là pour l'autre une immense estime
tandis que l'affrontement avec staline
ça va être beaucoup plus grave car les
deux hommes n'ont rien qui puisse les
rapprocher rien absolument rien alors
cette fois trotsky va de plus en plus
prendre une position d'opposant il est
contre il est contre par exemple la
politique qui veut que on est décidé de
ne faire seulement la révolution pour le
moment qu'en union soviétique et de
renoncer à la révolution mondial après
les échecs de hongrie et d'allemagne et
trotski est contre et dix ans qu'il
n'est pas contre seulement staline mais
là qu'il est contre l'immense majorité
du parti et du pays
et puis trotsky dénonce déjà la
centralisation bureaucratique et là
disons qu'il a raison l'avenir lui
donnera raison
mais cette fois cette opposition devient
plus qu'active il y à des émeutes en
union soviétique
des émeutes où on se réclame du nom de
trotski alors cela staline et ceux qui
l'entourent ne peuvent pas le supporter
on n'est pas encore au temps de la
prééminence absolue de staline
on n'est pas encore au temps du règne
sanglant de staline alors contre un
opposant aussi actif on prend une mesure
on exclut trotsky du parti sas et en 27
et puis on 29 ont l'exil
il est conduit à la frontière il ne peut
pas rester encore rester davantage en
union soviétique et récepteurs qui est
parti avec sa femme nathalie qui est à
istanbul et qui est semble-t-il tout
seul c'est un colosse mais un colosse
terrasse et qu'est ce qu'il reste de
trotski devant l'énorme machine de la
russie soviétique avec son chef staline
qu'est ce que c'est que cet exil et
qu'il ne fait qu'en portée des papiers
avec lui justement il a des papiers il a
du papier il a une plume et cet homme en
exil se met à écrire et où qu'ils soient
ils attaquent ils attaquent staline avec
une violence extraordinaire fantastique
alors bien sûr il fait peur cet homme
seul et on le chasse de partout alors
l'eau cette année rend trotsky il va de
turquie jusqu'en norvège
ils demandent asile à l'allemagne mais
on le lui refuse ils demandent asile à
l'angleterre on me refuse ils demandent
asile à la suisse on lui refuse
il reste huit jours au danemark à peine
en france en france on accueille tout de
même le gouvernement daladier en 1933
l'accueil mais il ne restera pas
longtemps car ce que évidemment c'est le
moment où le front populaire pointent à
l'horizon
c'est le moment de l'alliance franco
soviétique est cet homme qui est là qui
attaque qui attaque qui attaque sans
cesse qui maintenant vient même de
fonder avec impudence dit staline une
quatrième internationale
et bien cet homme là on le craint et on
la peur surtout que s'enveniment
peut-être les relations avec un pays qui
est notre allié et on demande finalement
à trotski de partir mais oui at-il il
chassait de partout il ya alors à ce
moment-là un pays à pays qui s'ouvrent
ce pays c'est le mexique le président
cardona c'est un homme qui est libéral
qui accueille les proscrits il
accueillera beaucoup de proscrits de la
guerre d'espagne et cet homme au destin
tragique qui est léon trotsky et bien
cardenas était mue par lui et lui dit
venez
et c'est alors que trotsky prend le
bateau arrive et devient l'hôte du
mexique
[Musique]
mexico il a trouvé une maison dans un
quartier de la grande banlieue
coyot à cannes là au coin de la rue de
vienne et la rue morelos il a trouvé une
grande maison de style tropical qui l'a
achetée grâce aux subsides de ses amis
trotskiste américain car il ya des
trotskistes nous le monde entier ce
n'est pas un parti puissant mais il
existe et cette maison il a
immédiatement transformé en forteresse
la ceinture en littéralement d'un énorme
mur en béton
et puis la porte il l'a remplacée par
une porte blindée il y à des fils qui
courent partout au dessus le long de ses
murs et la moindre tentative d'attaqué
se traduirait par des signaux sonores
lumineux et à l'intérieur de cette
maison il y a 6 garde en permanence
deux jeunes américains pour la plupart
qui par fidélité à trotski sont venus le
rejoindre
et puis des dehors il y à un poste de
police
dix policiers qui gardent en permanence
alors vous allez vous demander mais
enfin pourquoi
et d'ailleurs à mexico au départ on
n'est pas loin de penser que le vieux
comme on l'appelle maintenant le vieux
trotz qui exagèrent qu'il veut faire
parler de lui que mon dieu ça fait un
certain effet de propagande d'avoir
cette maison cette forteresse d'avoir
l'air de craindre pour sa vie
ce que les mexicains ne savent pas c'est
que léon trotsky a des raisons léon
trotsky sait que sa soeur olga a été
déportés par staline et qu'elle est
morte
léon trotsky c'est que le gendre son
gendre le gendre de trotsky a été arrêté
déporté que sa fille olga s'est suicidé
léon trotsky c'est que son fils serge
qui travaillait dans une usine en union
soviétique a été accusée d'avoir
empoisonné ses camarades et comme tels
des portes et on n'a plus jamais entendu
parler de lui l'hérault trotsky c'est
que ce son second fils léon est mort
mystérieusement à paris sans qu'on sache
comment et pourquoi est on trop de ski
c'est que depuis quelques mois se
déchaîne a moscou les fameux procès les
procès de moscou est que la tous les
vieux bolchéviks tous les vieux
révolutionnaire de la première heure
ceux qui ont fait la révolution cela
l'un après l'autre sont traduits à la
barre par staline on les dénonce
ce sont des criminels et ils l'avouent
ce sont des espions et ils l'avouent et
surtout qui les a guidés qui les a
conduits dans leurs criminels trahison
et bien c'est trotsky et ça il le jour
tous être ce qu'il sait et c'est que ce
sont ses amis ses vieux amis qui le
dénoncent avant d'aller au poteau
d'exécution
il se dit mais alors staline qui a fait
mourir les miens stallings qui déclenche
sa purge en me prenant comme prétexte
comme pierre de touche et bien moi
l'obstacle c'est moi qu'on va supprimer
il sait qu'il ya déjà eu un attentat
contre lui en europe alors ils se
replient dans sa forteresse dans sa
maison derrière son mur de béton
derrière cette tour dans lequel il a mis
des mitrailleuses
il est là comme à l'abri il ne sort pas
alors évidemment qu'il pourrait renoncer
par crainte mais ne rompt relance parce
que vous croyez que trotski est un homme
à renoncer
et c'est à ce moment là que sa campagne
antistalinienne prend une ampleur
presque colossal il est interviewé par
le cinéma par la presse par tout ce qui
compte
aux états unis et il parle il démonte
les procès de moscou il déclare à tel
moment
regardez le procès verbal on dit que tel
des inculpés m'a rencontré à tel endroit
on donne le jour
et bien ce jour là j'étais ailleurs il
le prouve et peu à peu ses fameux procès
de moscou se vident de leur substance à
cause de trotski et la disant que si on
le comprend admirablement quand il parle
des procès de moscou
on ne peut pas le suivre longtemps quand
on lit d'autres de ses écrits parce que
c'est écrit sens à un moment donné au
moins autant consacrer à la triptyque du
communisme stalinien et mondiale qu'à la
critique du capitalisme et oui ce vieux
révolutionnaire ce se perd tout à coup
et ça c'est une autre tragédie
c'est d'ailleurs la fatalité des exilés
des émigrés il ya un moment où on ne
sait plus à force de d'avoir raison à
force de condamner le régime de son pays
et bien on s'en prend quand même à ce
pays aussi et où est la limite
et ça les émigrés ne sort jamais où est
la limite et trotsky pas plus que les
autres et pourtant cette vie est là dans
cette maison où ils travaillent tous les
jours on se lève à 6h du matin
à 8 heures il est à sa table de travail
il est là avec nathalie qu'il aime
profondément
ils travaillent là 12 à 14 heures par
jour la nuit du 24 au 25 mai 1940 tout
dort dans la maison de kollo a call to
door sauf le garde car il y a toujours
un homme qui veille la nuit les il se
relève
cet homme s'appelle robert sheldon rapt
c'est un américain il a 25 ans c'est lui
qui veille et le reste dort léon trotsky
nathalie trotsky par la même chambre
leur petit fils le fils de léon celui
qui vit et mort à paris qui a 12 ans
dans la chambre voisine et puis les cinq
autres gardes garde secrétaire et puis
les trois domestiques mexicain et puis
deux amis français qui sont la d re
semaine et tout à coup voilà que les
montres de skier réveillé en sursaut sa
femme avec lui par un fracas des
explosions extraordinairement proche et
il dira le vieux il dira j'ai d'abord
cru que c'était des pétards parce que
les mexicains aime bien la nuit tout à
coup pour n'importe quel prétexte faire
partir des pétards et puis mac qui est
tellement fait la guerre je sais
reconnaître un coup de feu j'ai compris
très vite que c'était des coups de feu
et des coups de feu très très proches
réflexe immédiate il pousse nathalie
hors du lit il glisse lui même à terre
et sont là dans un coin
allongée sur le sol pas un geste pas un
mouvement voilà plein mitraillade se
rapproche la fenêtre vole en éclats et
un homme dans la fenêtre tire tire à la
mitrailleuse ballet la pièce
littéralement un autre s'encadre dans la
porte c'est prévu
était prévu à une minute près 1 mètre
près l'autre arrive et prend un autre
angle de la pièce avec une autre
mitrailleuses c'est comme un balayage un
double balayage et ils aperçoivent qui
sont toujours étendu sur le sol
ils aperçoivent dans l'encadrement que
l'homme un uniforme de police et ne
bougent pas aidé miraculeusement
ils ne sont pas atteints trotsky sera
juste effleuré la jambe et fleurs et par
humain ils attendent
puis un cri un appel les hommes qui
croient avoir fait leur besogne et ils
l'ont fait parce que le matelas est
entièrement criblé de balles les
oreillers sont transpercés de balle s'il
avait été dans leurs lits les témoins à
cri des hommes qui se rassemblent une
porte qu'on claque au loin un double
bruit de moteur ce sont deux voitures
qui démarre plus rien le silence et
trotsky qui se relève et sa femme qui se
relève et qu'ils aperçoivent alors que
l'homme qui était dans l'encadrement de
la porte a posé un récipient sur le sol
et voilà qu'une flamme 100 élèves c'est
une bombe incendiaire droite qui se
précipitent réussi à l'éteindre
il en est un drap une autre l'instant
d'après cas les hommes ont voulu non
seulement les tuer mais faire brûler la
maison
trotsky dira plus tard il y avait 76 kg
de papier dans cette maison et ne
fallait pas qu'il me survivre ses
papiers
la police est là
une demi-heure après c'est le colonel
salazar le directeur de la police
secrète de mexico qui est venu en
personne à el arish saute de sa voiture
devant la maison et voit les hommes du
poste de garde souvenez vous ils étaient
dix 10 policiers en permanence jour et
nuit et ils les avise les intervalles
mais alors quoi je rêve
vous êtes dit cela vous avez laissé
attaquer la maison et à l'intérieur ils
sont six ils ont deux mitrailleuses dans
des tours et la porte blindée mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors les
policiers lui raconte mon colonel
il y a vingt hommes qui sont arrivés il
était en uniforme de police comme nous
on l'a cru que c'était des renforts nous
ont parlé amicalement on les a laissés
approcher sans méfiance mais quand ils
nous ont mis la mitrailleuse dans le
ventre mais alors c'était trop tard et
en effet c'était trop tard c'était
évident attaque surprise attaques
réussies mais enfin salazar s'étonne
toujours aidé bon d'accord ils vous ont
eu ou non peut pas rentrer dans cette
maison il faut donner le signal il faut
donner un mot de passe on n'ouvre jamais
la porte alors ils ont sonné on l'a
rouvert non disent les policiers
il ya un homme qui semble être le chef
qui a parlé à travers la porte
il semble qu'il y avait quelqu'un
derrière la porte car on l'a ouverte
tout de suite et ils sont entrés
immédiatement dans la cour et alors on a
entendu les coups de feu et après ils
sont partis voilà salazar entre voix
trotsky voit son petit fils qui lui a
été légèrement blessé au pied
c'est incroyable qu'avec cette
mitraillade une petite blessure au pied
pour le petit fils et une légère
blessure à la jambe pour trotsky
c'est tellement incroyable que salazar
un moment aura des doutes et se dira
mais ce que ça n'a pas été préfabriquées
est ce que ce n'est pas trop de ce qui
est voulu se rendre intéressant et puis
l'enquète prouvera très vite que ça
n'est pas allant d'un attentat inventée
que c'est un véritable attente et même
la police va marquer des points assez
rapidement le pas mauvaise cette police
de mexico si l'on en croit les récits
que nous avons notamment celui du
colonel salazar lui même qui a raconté
en détail toute cette opération
c'est le hasard d'abord dans un café de
receveurs d'autobus qui parle et qui
disent ah les uniformes dont parlent les
journaux
bien sûr bas les uniformes ion ans et
c'est le juge qui les a passées
immédiatement on interroge les deux
hommes qu'est ce qu'ils ont voulu dire
ils disent que ils ont entendu dire qui
a le juge de leur quartier qui aurait
gagné ses costumes ses unifa
alors on va voir le juge qui dit mais
oui écouter non c'est un faux bruits il
est exact can mes amis est venu me voir
pour me demander des uniformes
j'ai le pouvoir en effet par ma fonction
de débloquer des uniformes ils voulaient
des uniformes pour faire peur à des
réactionnaires mais moi vous savez ce
qui est illégal ça ne m'intéresse pas
j'ai refusé mais qu'elle a mis elle
donne le nom martinez retrouve le nommer
martinez qui reconnaît qu'il a bien
demandé ces uniformes mais que ça n'est
pas lui ce n'était pas pour lui ces
uniformes mais pour un commandant des
brigades internationales de la guerre
d'espagne
alors on va voir le commandant qui dit
ben oui c'est exact que j'ai dit ça
martinez mais ça n'était pas pour moi le
policier passionne dans ces cas là et le
commandant des brigades internationales
donne le nom de l'homme à qui on a livré
les uniformes
c'est un est incertain nestor sanchez on
arrête
nestor sanchez qu'on retrouve hélas on
se trouve en présence de l'un des hommes
qui ont attaqué la maison de trotski
on leur a parlé on connaîtra la vérité
par lui on sera qu'ils étaient une
vingtaine tous déguisés tous armés et
qu'ils avaient deux chefs là était un
peintre un certain david alfaro
siqueiros et l'autre un juif français
donc ce n'est que bien plus tard qu'on
découvrira l'identité grigori
rabinovitch alors ils sont allés dans la
nuit ont désarmé les policiers comme
vous le savez est alors et c'est là que
ça nous intéresse et bien alors en effet
on leur a ouvert et c'est robert sheldon
art qui leur a ouvert
robert celle d'un art qui avait disparu
pendant cette nuit est donc maintenant
mr sanchez dit mais bien sûr qu'il a
disparu puisqu'il est revenu avec nous
après c'est même lui qui a conduit l'une
des deux voitures ont dit ça trotsky qui
ne veut pas ne veut pas croire à la
trahison de ce jeune américain si
sympathiques sont fidèles celle d'un art
et qui malgré toutes les apparences de
trahison ne veut pas y croire
et puis une autre piste qui conduit dans
le désert de los leones dans une ferme
abandonnée
hélas la terre a été franchement
fraîchement remuée en creuse et on
trouve le cadavre de roberte celle d'un
art de balle dans la tête
probablement les gens pour qui il avait
travaillé le souhaite et il pas que lee
et de témoins gênants et là on rapporte
encore ça trotsky et malgré l'évidence
il ne veut pas y croire il fera même
apposé une plaque dans la cour de la
ville là à la mémoire de robert sheldon
at assassiné par staline
parce que pour tout ce qu il n'y a aucun
doute c'est staline qui organise et
pourtant il se remet au travail
et pourtant il recommence sa vie
cependant chaque matin et c'est sa femme
qui l'a rapporté chaque matin quand il
se réveille il dit à sa femme et bien tu
vois nous sommes vivants il repart
s'occuper de ses lapins qui s'occupe de
ces lapins ça c'est sa grande
distraction le matin jusqu'à 8 heures il
est là près des clapiers nettoie les
cages donne à manger aux lapins s'occupe
d'eux et puis il part travailler et ce
jour là c'était le 20 août 1940 il avait
travaillé de nouveau toute la journée
quant à 17h30 un peu fatigué par ce
labeur acharné il écrivait à ce moment
là une vie de staline
on imaginait bien ce qu'elle allait être
cette vie de staline fatigué par ce
travail vers 17h30 il se lève sans va
faire un tour de jardin et retour voir
ses lapins décidément les lapins
nathalie le rejoint et puis on ouvre la
porte blindée ne s'ouvrent co familier
et nathalie aperçoit de loin a nommé
jacques sonne aulnat pense un petit
débordante pour ce jaxxon ce jacques
sonne bien
elle l'a connu par une grande amie des
trotsky qui s'appelle sylvie âge et lov
et qui a connu elle se jaxxon qu'il
s'appelait d'ailleurs pas jackson mais
mornar qu'il a connue en france l'année
d'avant elle faisait un séjour à paris
elle a connu un mot renard qui faisait
vaguement du journalisme qui lui a fait
la cour elle est devenue sa maîtresse
et puis elle est repartie pour new york
eut pied il lui a écrit beaucoup
beaucoup et lettres enflammées
décidément le grand amour disant qu'ils
avaient besoin
la revoir qu'il aller la rejoindre mais
comment faire car la guerre venait
d'éclater nous étions en 39 l'automne 39
il était déserteurs ne voulait pas se
battre et enfin il arrive à new york et
il raconte qu'il a eue pu obtenir un
faux passeport au nom de frank jackson
désormais on l'appellera frank jackson
et se borne à vie un mois très heureux
avec sylvia gel of a new york
et puis trouve une situation à mexico
alors qu'il la quitte
on continue à correspondre est très
amoureuse elle le rejoint en janvier
1940 à mexique
elle reste en janvier février mars à la
fin de mars
elle doit regagner new york elle dit
écoute je vais aller prendre congé de
trotski que mornar jackson n'avait
jamais vu jusque là si tu veux viens
avec moi je te présente très à droite ce
qui est mon art jaxxon et très heureux
parce que à paris alors que ses opinions
politiques que tu es assez fluctuante
ayant rencontré sylvia jay l'ofs elle
lui avait parlé de trotski du trotskisme
et lui même s'étaient pris de sympathie
pour cette doctrine alors ils allaient
maintenant rencontrer le vieux le vieux
lutteur
alors il a été présenté quelques mots
c'est tout elle est repartie mais lui
prenant prétexte de cette première
entrevue lui est revenu roussin a prêté
des visites qui ont compté ils étaient
reçus par les gardes il échangé quelques
mots lisait comment va le seigneur
trotsky bas très bien il travaille ça
n'allait pas plus loin que ça
jusqu'au jour où il se trouvait là alors
que les français vous savez ce dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure ce qui
était là lors du premier attentat les
français ont voulu retourner en europe
il fallait une voiture pour les emmener
à la vera cruz et jackson mornar s'est
proposé
on l'accepté les français sont partis
avec lui et aussi nathalie nathalie
trotsky qui les a accompagnés jusqu'à la
vera cruz elle est même revenu seul avec
jackson
ça crée des liens
quelques jours après il est venu
apporter un planeur pour le petit fils
alors les trois de ce qu'ils ont invités
à partager leur petit déjeuner et puis
quelques jours encore après quelques
semaines peut-être nous sommes au 18 ou
1940 il s'est présenté à la maison de la
rue de vienne en demandant à parler à
trotski lui même trop ce qu'il a reçu et
il avait un article à la main c'était un
article manuscrits et voulait demander à
trotski ce qu'il en pensait trotsky la
lui a eu du mal
non seulement c'était très mal écrit
mais aussi les idées étaient confuses et
il a donné quelques conseils reprenait
cet article des idées claires vous savez
n'y a que la clarté en fait
et puis ça que taper sera peut-être
mieux et puis justement le vin tout la
journée où nous sommes contre ce qui est
là devant les lapins à 17h30 avec natal
il revient c'est jackson qui revient et
il dit qu'il a fait taper l'article
qu'il l'a repris il voudrait que trotsky
le lise
c'est très beau si l immaculée pourtant
il a un imperméable très lourd qui lui
pend sur le bras il un chapeau sur la
tête pourquoi cet imperméable dit
nathalie il peut pleuvoir roi dans la
pas l'air si vous êtes si pâle qu'est ce
qui a vous êtes malade
c'est vrai que s'il vient m'a dit que le
climat ne vous réussissez pas voulait
pas prendre du thé non j'ai mal digéré
mon déjeuner je préfère un verre d'eau
et on lui apporte un verre d'eau
et puis
trotsky le prend par le bras allez venez
de lire votre article
nathalie les accompagne jusqu'à la porte
du bureau elle le laisse tout seul dans
le bureau de passe dans la pièce voisine
hélas deux ou trois minutes après tout à
coup elle entend un cri affreux un
hurlement épouvantable déchirant
strident horrible affolé elles courent
pas sur la terrasse est là elle voit
tout à coup dans l'encadrement de la
porte de salle à manger son mari trotsky
là debout
appuyez sur le chambranle il a perdu ses
lunettes
elle ne voit plus que les yeux très
bleus et du sang du sang qui y ont le
visage
le cesi balles par les bras et lui dit
mais quoi quoi il répond avec une voix
très nette très distinctes mais
curieusement d' distinctes justement il
articule et il dit
jacques sonne
elles portent presque l'aide à s'étendre
sur une natte se penche vers lui
et alors il la regarde toujours et lui
dit toujours cette voix distinctes
natacha je t'aime elle va chercher un
oreiller du coton pour éponger le sens
de la glace pour mettre sur la plaie
béante ouverte dans le crâne il y a
décrit dans la maison des hurlements les
gardes qui ont couru vers le bureau
encore cette voie il ne faut pas qu'il
le tue il faut qu'il parle
et puis une explication tu sais il a
voulu me frapper encore je l'en avait
empêché il y assure son visage comme une
sorte de fierté
et c'est vrai parce que maintenant les
hommes ont couru en trouver ce mot
renard qui s'abritent de leurs coûts et
ils le frappent à coups de crosse il y
en a qui se cassera la main à force de
lui martelé le visage et marne à redire
à un peu plus tard comment ça s'est
passé comment il est entré comme il a
donné l'article et trotsky s'est
détournée pour le lire peut-être pour
chercher la lumière
et pendant ce temps il a pris l'autre a
pris l'imperméable qu'il a posés sur un
meuble et à tirer de cet imperméable un
piolet un piolet d'alpinisme hewitt il
connaît donc il connaissait bien le
maniement savez un de ces piaule et
quand on le frappe dans la glace d'un
glacier en enlève un bloc de glace
il était derrière trotsky il a levé le
piolet de toutes ses forces la asséné et
alors c'est là que trotsky a poussé ses
hurlements affreux épouvantable et s'est
retournée comme une bête comme comme un
combattant peut être aussi hélas ici il
est quelque chose d un geste inouï
il a saisi de la main gauche
deux mots renard la main droite étant
encore occupée par le piolet la porter à
sa bouche et l'a mordu à enfoncer cédant
jusqu'à l'os enlevant toute possibilité
à mort noir de frapper de nouveau et
alors le cri les hommes qui accourent et
lui dira mornar lui qui s'en va comme un
fantôme déjà debout lentement qui s'en
va vers la porte alors le médecin qui
arrive qui se penchent qui regardent la
plaie qui avale sa salive et qui dit ça
ne sera rien et trotsky qui regardent
l'un de ses gardes secrétaire g qui dit
moi je sens là que c'est la fin on
l'amènera à l'hôpital dans l'ambulance
en anglais il donnera un dernier message
à l'un de ses gardes secrétaire en
anglais pour ne pas alarmer sa femme et
il dira chez confiance dans le triomphe
de la quatrième internationale en lavant
à l'hôpital on viendra lui couper les
cheveux et il ya déjà des jours et des
jours que sa femme lui disait il faut
faire venir le coiffeur voyant et quand
on vient lui couper les cheveux il dit
tu vois le coiffeur
et puis on veut le déshabiller le dit
non non non toi qui tire à sa fin
c'est elle qu'il le déshabille quand
elle a fini elle pose ses lèvres sur les
siennes et lui rend son baiser
longuement c'est leur dernière à dieu
car il perd conscience l'opération ne le
sauvera pas il luttera encore toute la
nuit le lendemain il mourra le soin
après 25 heures de lutte
il faut qu'ils parlent allaient-ils dit
eh bien oui il faut que monaco mornar
parle mais va-t-il parler alors il
raconte qu'il est né à téhéran que son
père et ministre plénipotentiaire de
belgique qu'il a fait ses études à
l'école militaire de dixmude que sa mère
habitait chaussée dieu de vabres il
donne le numéro on appelle le ministre
plénipotentiaire de bébé de belgique de
mexico lui démontre qu'il n'y a jamais
eu de mots renard dans le corps
diplomatique belge qu'il n'y a pas
d'école militaire à dixmude et que le
numéro de la chaussée de wavre et bien
tout simplement c'est celui d'un grand
magasin qui occupe tout l'immeuble et il
dit mornar n'est pas belge
alors
alors qui est morne on découvrira la
police découvrir que le fameux passeport
qu'il déclare faux frank jackson porte
un numéro ferait que c'est celui d'un
canadien qui quelque temps plus tôt
quelques années plus tôt a quitté le
canada pour l'espagne pour aller se
battre dans les brigades internationales
et quand on arrivait dans les brigades
internationales on remettait son passe
pas plus tard le canadien est mort on
s'est servi de ce passeport mais par
quel chemin le passeport est il passé
les brigades internationales à mornas la
police des brigades internationales
étaient en grande partie assuré par la
nkvd soviétique
il ya donc un lien qui semble
indiscutable entre les deux actions on
va juger mornas il sera condamné au
maximum de la peine 20 ans et ce n'est
que bien plus tard après la seconde
guerre mondiale qu'on éclaircira le
mystère de son origine car il n'est pas
belge
il n'est pas mort nar il n'est pas
jacques sonne c'est d'abord julian
gorkin qui émettra l'hypothèse est plus
tard un grand médecin légiste et
psychiatre mexicain qui poursuivra
l'enquète le docteur qu'heroes que c'est
grâce au docteur qui rose que nous avons
maintenant une certitude absolue
le vrai nom de mots renard et ramon
mercader del rio c'est le fils d'une
révolutionnaires espagnols caridad
mercader del rio toute une famille
consacré à la révolution
ramon mercader del rio qui se battent
dans la guerre d'espagne qui est blessé
et puis ensuite qui part peut-être pour
moscou où il suit les leçons de l'école
d'espionnage
qui revient à paris et qu'il a exécuté
sa mission rencontre sylvia jay l'ofs
la suite vous la connaissez il
accomplira oui c'est 20 ans de prison
il se mariera en prison quelques temps
avant sa libération aura un enfant
et quand il est libéré le 13 mai 1940 et
bien c'est en famille qu'il prendra
l'avion pour cuba d'abord et ensuite
pour la tchécoslovaquie au delà du
rideau de fer
voilà l'histoire de ramon mercader
l'assassin de trotski mais on a dit
qu'il avait été décoré par staline avant
la mort de celui-ci de l'ordre du héros
de l'union soviétique cela n'est pas
confirmé mais à propos de staline
justement comme on aimerait savoir ce
qu'a pensé ramon mercader del rio en
arrivant là bas
au delà du rideau de fer parce que le
survivant du grand duel
le dernier survivant staline était mort
à son tour et puis l'union soviétique
avait dénoncé ces crimes
par la bouche de crutchlow et puis les
victimes du procès de moscou tous ceux
qui étaient morts en à table entre
autres ce qui est bien c'est gens là
avaient été réhabilités solennellement
et ceux qui avaient probablement
organisé le crime c'est-à-dire béria et
ses collaborateurs et bien cela avait
été exécuté comme des criminels alors
à quoi pensait en regagnant cette partie
du monde
ramon mercader del rio qui sur ordre
avait naguère tués
léon trotski
[Musique]